- The philosophy in our collection
has always been that the
specimens are here to be used.
So every animal will
eventually find a purpose here.
I'm Alan Resetar, McCarter
Collections Manager
in the Amphibian and Reptile Collection
at Field Museum.
We are gonna be unboxing
the Komodo dragons today.
The Komodo dragon is the
world's largest lizard.
It's not the world's longest lizard,
but the Komodo is the largest.
Our Komodo dragons are kept
in this specially custom-made,
stainless steel tank,
which is over 100 gallons.
And a Komodo dragon about
this size would weigh about
oh, maybe about 125 pounds.
His organs were removed when
he was necropsied at the zoo,
so he's a little bit lighter,
but he's still pretty heavy.
Almost all of our 300,000 specimens
in the collection are in 70% ethanol.
So essentially, what
we do is buy Everclear.
The same product you can
buy at the liquor store.
We purchase it in 55-gallon drums.
And being a museum, we can
apply for a special permit
so we don't have to pay
the liquor tax on it.
So that saves us a little money.
The specimens are here
for scientific research.
So they're here to be shared
with students and researchers
from all over the world.
They don't come out as often as I'd like.
They were here probably about 18 years
before somebody conducted
the first research project on them.
But the animals are here forever.
I mean, our goal is to keep
them for hundreds of years.
Even though a specimen may
sit here a couple decades,
all of a sudden there might be
a research interest in them.
You know, we can move this,
we just make sure that
nobody's in a empty aisle.
I almost crushed a guy
from Argentina one time.
(laughs)